from the OG MILF to evil stepmom to bend
and snap Pro to the now legendary Canyon
mcquad if you aren't a fan of Jennifer
coolidge's comedic genius who do you
think you are are you lost
no but honestly I could sing her Praises
forever we could not talk or talk
forever and still find things to not
talk about so today I'm going to be
taking a page out of some of Jennifer's
most iconic roles and building a day of
eating inspired by a Golden Globe
winning Queen hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
like award-winning actress Jennifer
Coolidge well like not really which
you're about to see but a reminder that
this is just what I ate on a random day
and is not meant to be copied or
recommended as how you should eat so
always speak to a registered dietitian
about your unique needs also if you're
new here don't forget to subscribe to
this Channel and ring that Bell and
follow me on Instagram and Tick Tock at
Abby's kitchen so according to the Daily
Mail Jennifer Coolidge almost turned
down the iconic role of Tanya mcquad
because she gained 40 pounds during
covid and thought she was too fat to
take the gig like so many of us in the
early dark days of the pandemic Jennifer
fan herself depressed entering to food
to try to cope telling news outlets and
I quote I thought we were all going to
die I really did so I was eating myself
to death allegedly eating five or six
vegan pizzas every day and Stifler's mom
is not alone research suggests that over
48 percent of people experience pandemic
related weight gain aka the covet 15
often related to stress lonely lonely
anxiety depression and financial strain
but aside
very relatable
there really isn't a whole lot of
details about what Jennifer Coolidge
eats or her diet anywhere online which
is fascinating to me because if you type
any other celebrity's name in plus diet
on Google you'll get dozens of pages
outlining their so-called plan and I
guess that's to be expected when you're
not already a size 2 or haven't publicly
dropped a ton of weight for a roll
hashtag Hollywood problems but I digress
despite the disappointing dearth of
details out there on Jennifer coolidge's
alleged diet I actually thought it'd be
more fun to piece together some meals
from some of Jennifer's most iconic
movie roles but of course make it all
vegan because that is like the one
detail that I could actually find online
about Jennifer coolidge's actual diet
but my stomach is growling I am hungry
so Abby let's get started
thank you
I am beyond excited about today I am a
huge Jennifer Coolidge fan I think she's
a comedic genius and I thought I
would like Channel a little Jennifer
Vibes this felt like this felt a little
White Lotus maybe so there may be a
Lotus on this it's a Lotus I don't know
it's a flower that I am not familiar
with but I've got my obligatory coffee
and I am dying of starvation right now
so talk breakfast to me girl
are you lost
[Music]
except for his mom I
huh
no folks I could not do a Jennifer
Coolidge diet without paying homage to
one of the most iconic movie roles of
all time Stifler's mom that's stiffler's
mom
[Music]
well I would not snub like apple pie
straight up for breakfast I do think we
can make it like a little more satiating
while still getting that warm apple pie
experience in my mouth obviously you
should put your mouth on that
how can you even use that one naturally
but even that sounds bad let's make
breakfast
it is Monday is it it's
Tuesday but it's like a holiday Monday
situation so I'm not with it yet oatmeal
let's do it Abby oats down
all right and we're keeping a
plant-based for you Jennifer so I'm
using some pea milk to bump up the
protein throw that bad boy in
some healthy fats
and parts
it's good
and we need a lid okay oh salt
you cannot make oats without salt
stick that down there and for the apple
pie experience I'm just going to kind of
caramelize some chopped apples a little
avocado oil throw that down
we're gonna need some cinnamon up in
here okay cinnamon
flat got some brown sugar
which I love to use the Demerara sugar
just like adds this like crunch Factor
all right let's let that soften I'm
gonna add a little bit of vanilla
might need more milk
and I'm going to add some vanilla
protein powder
plant-based of course and you smell
what The Rock
[Applause]
smells good I like a little salt
with anything sweet so little fancy salt
pecans
if I can ever figure out how to open the
bag
might as well toast these up a little
bit because that's going to be our
topper
oh
run away
all right let's plate her up okay folks
this smells amazing but I also just
realized I have a pie crust candle
pretty sure it's vegan pretty sure the
candle's vegan We're not gonna eat it
but we're gonna smell it for The Full
Experience
smells like Stifler's mom you know or
what I would imagine she's not like
delicious
um
do you guys remember that apples and
spice Quaker oatmeal packets that used
to eat as a kid
it's better and I'm not gonna say it's
as good as Third Base when you're a
virgin but
I'm a mama too and sometimes just eating
my breakfast alone in quiet
is better than sex sorry not sorry
[Music]
it is lunch time and I got two early
2000s bangers for you A Cinderella Story
and Legally Blonde leave me in the
comments below which was your fave oh my
God you look like the Fourth of July
that makes me want a hot dog real bad
is this Norwegian salmon that I asked
for because I need my omega-3s only the
best so I'm actually really excited
about this I mean as you guys know I'm
not plant-based myself so if someone
offers me a hot dog at like a barbecue
and that's all there is I'm not gonna
say no but when I have the choice I
actually prefer the taste of these bad
boys not to mention I know this is like
super weird to say but
the hot dog water like it smells like
real hot dog water like I don't know how
they manufacture that or what like in
what lab were they trying to perfect hot
dog water I I don't know but I'm glad
that they did like smell this
you're weird buddy you're weird taste
aside smell aside I actually have some
pretty decent stats Abby can you compare
for us you got it so first of all I'm
not into food fear-mongering because the
Fourth of July Vibes also makes me want
an OG hot dog real bad but if
it comes to Classic ballpark there are
some nutritional distinctions so for one
we do have a solid amount of evidence
that highly processed meat products like
hot dogs have been associated with
cancer cardiovascular disease and
all-cause mortality veggie dogs are not
necessarily a super health food either
as they are still considered highly
processed and high in salt but compared
to the OG they are typically lower in
fat and higher in Protein Plus are
generally nitrate free veggie dogs also
have a surprisingly solid amount of iron
and B vitamins for convenience food so
yeah I'm not mad we're going plant-based
with Jennifer today These Wings Are
small so I'm gonna do like
two in a bun can I I'm gonna do too
we've even got the authentic
hot dogs sweat
look at that they mastered it
Geniuses all right love this journey for
us but I'm gonna get some veg in there
and that bougie sounding smoked salmon
salad from Norwegian I'm here for it and
I wouldn't even be surprised if like the
salmon diet was a legit thing back in
the 2000s those were dark days but
obviously we're going plant-based today
and I managed to find this plant-based
smoked salmon it's made out of carrots
with some sugar and apple cider vinegar
and some oil and seaweed and some flax
oil so as they tell us here it's a
source of Omega-3 polyunsaturates it was
inexpensive I'm not gonna lie so it
better be damn good and the downside is
we're really not going to be getting a
ton of Omega-3s that we would be getting
in real salmon so compensate I'm gonna
add
lots of hemp hurts on top just load her
up not the equivalent but still a
nutritious addition Abby can you walk us
through the difference between
plant-based and marine-based Omega-3s so
most of the major benefits that we hear
associated with Omega-3s like brain
health heart health and mental health
are largely linked to EPA and DHA
Omega-3s now the best sources of EPA and
DHA are in fatty fish now plant-based
Omega-3s come in the form of ala which
is an essential precursor to EPA and DHA
the problem is the conversion factor in
humans is really inefficient only one to
ten percent of ala gets converted to EPA
and only 0.5 to 5 into DHA so of course
every bit in the diet helps but if you
are fully plant-based it may be worth
taking an algae-based omega-3 supplement
to ensure you're meeting your needs love
me a little everything bagel seasoning
because it's just like you get that full
smear experience a little Italian
dressing which is already plant-based
and
I'm a ketchup
and mustard reality
excuse me
oh
guys This Is My Jam we got tons of
beautiful colors here we've got lots of
protein in our hot dogs healthy fats in
the avocado and the hemp seeds and of
course tons of high fiber carbs I mean
can you believe this little veggie dog
has eight grams of protein I'm not mad
about this meal I'm really not I am
definitely curious about the smoked
salmon experience so let's give that a
go first
yeah
it could pass
it could pass if you're not Jewish
and this is the hot dog
yup
the pickles
mm-hmm
they snap
I'm extremely confused this guys is
totally Paulette approved because as
Paulette would say herself I'm taking
the dog dumbass
okay let's talk dinner because I'm very
excited about this also if you have not
watched the White Lotus yet you are
hugely missing out also massive spoiler
alert here but what is the point of a
third season without Tanya mcquad just
tell me am I right
a real tragedy for our times honestly
alas to pay homage to season two's
dreamy South Italian backdrop of course
you know we've got to do the nudes it's
nudie man
out of there you know what I mean
[Music]
I mean we're gonna do a super simple
pasta elenorma which is a classic
Sicilian dish made with tomatoes garlic
and eggplant of course I could make the
sauce myself but why spend the time on
Ely does a perfectly good job at it so
I'm taking a shortcut because hashtag
motherhood and I have a feeling that
Tanya mcquad never cooked a meal in her
life just saying but while we wait for
the water to boil back there I poured
myself a little glass of the good stuff
Abby could you give us a little rundown
on the benefits or risks of red wine
as per usual it's complicated especially
in light of new guidelines here in
Canada that reduce the maximum
recommended weekly drinks from up to 15
down to just two that's quite the jump
but it is based on emerging research
that suggests anything beyond two drinks
a week puts you at elevated risk of
chronic diseases like cancers diabetes
heart disease liver disease and more now
on the flip side we also have evidence
suggesting that the antioxidant
Resveratrol in red wine may actually
reduce the risk of certain cancers it
may also help to boost cognitive
function support heart health and
regulate blood sugar so to drink or not
to drink
and this is a great example of the adage
the dose makes the poison what we
generally see in the literature when it
comes to alcohol is what we call a
j-shaped curve where a small amount of
alcohol may have a protective effect but
anything more and we see a huge uptick
in Risk risk is also likely extremely
individualized so bottom line I would
not aim to get your antioxidants from
wine but if you do choose to imbibe do
so in moderation no note I am too old
for hangovers anyway so
fair enough anyways
let's cook some pasta
you guys know I don't do the low carb
thing but one thing I love to do when
I'm making pasta is to mix my real nudes
with some zucchini noodles just so we
can get a little extra veg in there and
some extra fiber if you want to make
zucchini noodles that don't suck here's
a little tip salt them really good
and this is going to help to draw out
some of the moisture so that all that
water doesn't end up in your sauce so I
let that sit for about 10 minutes and
now I'm just gonna Pat it all dry
hmm
this is a bucatini my favorite nude it's
got a little hole in the middle
it does
I know that humans have seven holes ears
two
four five
six seven yeah
do women have more or is it all the same
hole
what technically no it's the same hole
well I guess like whatever I mean
technically you have AIDS actually yeah
like for peeing yeah it's different
slightly I think
yeah it is more difficult to open this
jar a sauce than it is to make it noted
for next time
a dry cleaning Bill if you don't mind
let's get all our bad boys in here okay
zucchini
[Music]
hello
a lot of chunky sauce
throw in
some mooch
for that cheesy flavor
and a couple of olives
whoo
upper wrong culture
what do the Italians say
oh forgot this ingredient white beans
protein
there we go folks
[Music]
it's a party guys this took me five
minutes and I'm not mad about it we've
got protein in our white beans and the
nooch we got healthy fats in the olive
oil and the olives here and tons of
fiber in our veg pasta And the sauce not
to mention it looks incredible
oh
thank you
that was hot
but damn good it's finally my favorite
part of the day dessert time brought To
Us by one of my favorite Coolidge lines
of all time you want a cookie
from Mars
I don't know why but maybe it's because
moist is one of like the most cringy
words in the dictionary when you add in
like a jenniferism it just becomes
totally unhinged that's it I love me a
good moist chocolate chip cookie
that make you mad so funny did that make
you mad did it offend you tell me in the
comments below do you want me to bleep
out moist every time I say it punch in
moist
moist oh anyway I'm not a baker I just
don't have the patience but I will take
any opportunity to get me some
store-bought cookie dough and this one's
completely plant-based and gluten-free
and peanut and nut free so let's bake
this off
15 minutes later for gluten-free and
vegan they look pretty good so and they
smell delicious will they be moist is
another question and I'm prepared to
answer it but first I want to show you a
little intuitive eating hack that will
completely change your perspective and
your relationship with your fear foods
like cookies if your goal is to put your
fear Foods on the same playing field as
all other Foods you need to literally
put them on the same plate so I want you
to take the food that you deem as like
junk or bad or unhealthy and literally
put it on the same plate as other foods
that provide more nourishment visually
seeing the healthy and unhealthy Foods
on the same plate puts them on the same
playing field it rips them off of their
pedestal it makes them all just another
food that can be enjoyed in moderation
so you don't have to have a full out
cookie inch or a super strict clean
eating day so try this little exercise
out yourself and let me know how it goes
for my little dessert Snack Pack I've
got the moist chocolate chip cookie I've
got some fruit here for some Fiber I've
got some crispy chickpeas for some Fiber
and protein and some pistachios for some
healthy fats and a little bit of protein
and fiber I'm going in for the cookie
first
hmm crispy on the outside
and moist on the inside she's a winner
oh
five second roll
so this was Loki such a fun day of eats
I got cookies I got a hot dog I got
apple pie I got pasta and wine Jennifer
Coolidge knows how to live not to
mention I will take any reason to
re-watch her Greatest Hits and I really
hope that Jennifer's code 15 or I guess
like covered 40 story serves as a good
reminder why you should never let your
weight stand in your way of
opportunities that light you up and
while it sounds like Jennifer was in a
rough place during covid and the events
that led up to her weight gain during
those years were really challenging for
her in the end those extra vegan pizzas
did not hurt her career if anything
she's thriving rip Tanya you will be
forever missed and on that note I hope
you guys like this style of video If You
did leave me a comment below on
different actors or movies or themes or
genres or decades that you guys want me
to explore in a wedding a day subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]